L
RUSSFOOWN A ITN TARGETS ON PURP.
G CIVILIANS.RKIVIN SECOND LARGES
SIAN STATE MEDIA, THOUGH
WOW. I
.T IS LIKE A HUMANITARIAN FORT
NIC ROBERTSONT WITH
T FROM MOSCOW.>> Reporter: TV,
BEING TOLD
WHAT THE KREMLIN WANTS THEM TO
KNOW ABO TN UKRAINE. RUSSIAN AR
MAID
FROMHECLAIFO NGIVILIANSAF
A MESSED IN
PRESIDENT TEEC
N ALARS lator: OUR MILITARY HAVE
eporter:ERRIBLE REST OF THE WOR
SEES?
F CIVILIANS, TH, AND
DESTRUCTION.R GETSN RUSSIAN
RUSSIANS
GO WAR WEM
BY
NOW THE TRUTH. WAS AORE
AFR  THROUGH
IN Wlar:ON
TV WHEN I
WORK.
WE TRY NOT TO GET TOIN
IN IT BEUSE WE'VGOOUGH  OWN
TO REACH BEYENOUGH
BUT EVEN THEN, THEY NO
CONVINCED BY WHA SEE
YES,  CIVIL CHILDREN,
THEY ARE MAKING MONE
OBEDIENT ONER QUESTION THE
REINITFICATION.T
ZELENSKYY  JEWISH OR
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL I.AR
EVEN YOUNGERRUSSIANS SEE THROUG
NEWS FRO INDEPENDENT T THEIR
MED ALMOST ALL OF US THIS TF LD
SO WNO
PPHIHI
CRIME.ANN AGAINST A TRY.
NOEIT'S A. THI
SITUATION BUT WE CAN'T DO PEOPLR
ID HIKE
>> Reporter: THE
SO, ME
COULD CHALLENGE THEIR NAIVW DAY
OUTLETS.
AND IS RIGHT NOW A LAW
CALLS FAKE MED. A5-TENCE.
SPE KREMLIN'
EFFORTS AT CONLI
NARRATIVE,ANIANS HAVE
TAKEN TO STREETS.
D BY P'S.
MORE THA7,
SO FAR.
INCLUDING, THIY LADY AT
SB
SURPRISE.
THIS VIDEO IT TO BE SHOWN ON
STATE ME
RIGHT NOW, THE TRUTHS
THE MOST
ESN AND  WHICH
WHI HS SO
THES
STIFLIHE IND RACKING DOWN, SHUT
DOWN INDEPDENT M
CNN LEARNED THAT
THBIRATION H
HELD AT LEAST SEVEN -- HELD
INWS WITH AT
RUSSIAN-LANGUAGE OUTLETS ECHO
MOOW R AND
INDEPENDENT STATIONSECHO MOSCOW
UP.
RAIN WAS ANOTR.
EW
TH ANCHOTHERE.
ID THAT,VE
LLD TESTIMOIME IS UEMN' USE THE
KNOW AEEHEAPED TO
EMERIN.
>> NIC, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NT TO GOO ED HIS H
TRAVELED FORE  30 HOURS
TO A SAFERFO UKRAINE WITH H F.
I -- I -- I HAVE TYOUR
IS HARD FOR  HEAA E
LIKE YOU J
C ROBE MOSCOW
NSBOSIOND MANY SAYING EY
ARE AGAINST THE WAR.
IS FAKE UT CIV AAMVENY ALSO G WE
THERE RES WHSA ME.
O KNOW
I WANT -- I'D LOVE
PE T
BVGRO S --
A MILIT THEY
G TOLD.
O SUCHOR HERE,N-SPEA
, THIS IS ABSOLUTEXPERIENCE.MY A
RUSSIA.S SITUATION,WANOTHING T
PP HER OR MO HO ARE RER N KIV I-
BOMBARDED.STANTL
KHARKIV RIT  LIKE THE
STALINGR
ANPOSTURE OF T STRONTH
RE ACTY M THEYTH LIV THEY
LATE.
AND THEY JUST TA
FA.
'S SO FA
ED OUTO HIM
JUST FOR FINCI
THIS -- INS CASE.
OUT TME KIND OF P THIS IS WHATI
WRG.AIHAD CAN YO US SOME WAY, A
SRECTLY
HEIDERE.
AND THATASF TH T DIVIDG  I
THIS WAY.
>> I AM SO SORRY FOR YGIRLFRIE .
MEST --  DAS
IMPOSSIBLE TO TRULY UNDERSTAND.
I DONOW,E,YO
DOCUMENTOUNE I SPOKE TO THE MAY
EARLIER THIS HOUR.S THERE.OUSLYI
SIRENS.
HE IS HEARING AS HE SPEAKS AND
TALKS ABOUT THEM.
EXTRARY.D ENORMOUSUMW VI CASUAS.
I KNBLY LUCKY
TO HAVE LEFT THET HAS
BEEN AN ARDUOUS JOURY RE
E NDNLSTOP ORHWHERE YOU MAY  INR
STATION.
YOU HAD  D, HOW WAS YOUR JOURNER
U ARE NO HOME.
IT WASIT LONAN
ALSO SOR WAITINGAMSINCE THE FIR
AFTHUNDERSTOOD OKAY, THIS  T AUB
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO STOP.
GEOUY , I HAFAMILY.
MOM AND MY GOU
WHIVING IN KHARKIVTH OF THESE P
IN
UNS. S EE NOT EVEN TRYIN
DAY, WE WERE JUST WAITING FOR --
SHELTEN MEY BEEN SITTING IN BOMB
TIME.AND LUCKIL PEOPLE, A FRIEN
IN
I.T.THAT
WAS TO TAKHAEVACUATION EFFORT F.
EYW BUSEERE.ANO DOWN THRGHUSLYE.
WE WENT DOWN THEN
THROUGH A FEW OTHER CITIES,
WHD  NOTAWAY RIGHTSENSITIVE
INFORMATN.ENTUALLY, WE MADE OU .
AN AS FOR THE E ARPLATIN
LADIL CONTINUE
GOING ON FURTH.
GONE ORTR T  WE SPEAK, ON THE
SISTEOULD  HUNGT .
BE CLOSE TLLOW MOM AND MY
YOUNGEST SIS ONL5 OLD.AT TE  BET
ERE IS USE IG WIFORMATION ANLOG
IGLLU ARE INY  AS THIS -- AS IS
EVERYO IAMD YOUR GLFE BUT E
ED BE THE RIGHT AND SAFEST
TH
>> THIS IS LIKE -- THE MAIED LI
-ANEF
ATHELPFUL.
IF THERE PJUSTHE
PARE THEY OUT AND THEYAN JOI
THEM HAVE TAKE EFFORTOSTOP BESAE
WE ARELLD TO H
COMPANIELI
OTHER REECES THAP
FOLLOWING THALLY U
THIS IS
ACTUALLY HELP UKRAINE DIRECTD U